[Musique]
donc atteint
depuis trois mois alicia bay avec
beaucoup d'attention sur un petit
pensionnaire
ce bébé tamanoir orphelins
quand on l'a trouvé il pesé 2,2 kg alors
qu'il aurait dû en faire au moins six il
avait perdu tous ses poils à cause du
stress de la malnutrition
mais maintenant il va super bien
quand il dépassera les 20 kg l'animal
pourra être relâchés comme la plupart de
ses congénères qui récupère dans ce
centre de soins
80% des tamanoir prise en charge ici so
réintroduit avec succès dans la nature
quand ils atteignent les dix mois ils ne
veulent plus qu'on les approche ou qu'on
ait de contact physique avec eux
donc on s'éloigne d'eux on leur apporte
à manger sans entrer dans l'enclos ils
prennent leurs distances c'est pour ça
que pour cette espèce la réintroduction
dans la nature est un vrai succès
en quinze ans le centre a remis en
liberté une centaine de tamanoir dans
cette province du nord-est de
l'argentine où ces animaux étaient
totalement absents depuis les années 50
leur adaptation à la vie sauvage est
ensuite surveillé en permanence grâce à
des pièges photographiques
une victoire pour la biodiversité
résultat des efforts d'une fondation
baptisée rewilding
depuis 2007 celle ci applique dans le
parc dit berra le principe durer ans
sauvagement la réintroduction dans leur
milieu naturel d'espèces disparues
dans cette région la deuxième plus
humide au monde des loutres géantes ou
encore des pécari sont de nouveau
visible
mais parfois ce retour à la nature
implique un long travail de préparation
je mets toujours leur nourriture en
hauteur car ce sont des animaux qu'ils
doivent apprendre à être en hauteur
c'est dangereux pour eux d'apprendre à
manger au sol
depuis plus de quatre ans et léna dirige
le centre d'entraînement des haras rouge
avant d'atterrir à ibera ces grands
perroquets ont passé leur vie dans des
eaux ou chez des particuliers
beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont jamais eu la
possibilité de voler parce qu'ils
vivaient dans des petites cages donc
c'est quelque chose qu'ils n'ont pas pu
développer allons seulement leur apprend
à voler mais aussi à devenir plus habile
qu'il soit capable d'éviter des
obstacles et aussi à se poser sur des
surfaces d'irrégulière
des exercices quotidiens qui dure en
moyenne plus d'un an pour s'assurer que
les oiseaux puissent survivre dans la
nature
pour ce groupe de ciara la libération
est prévue la semaine prochaine
mais ce retour de la faune sauvage ne
peut réussir sans le soutien des
communautés locales
originaire de la région juan travaille
depuis deux ans pour la fondation
rewilding sa mission expliquer aux
habitants que la réintroduction et la
protection des animaux sauvages peut
leur être bénéfique
via le développement du tourisme
avant la plupart des locaux gagner leur
vie en braconnant et aujourd'hui ils se
rendent compte qu'un animal vivant a
aussi beaucoup de valeur n'est pas
nécessaire de le tuer vivant il a aussi
un intérêt économique
ce jour là il est venu prendre des
nouvelles de mingo
cet ancien braconniers a pu créer son
entreprise de balades en bateau tirée
par un cheval un moyen de transport
traditionnel de la région une sortie de
deux heures lui rapporte environ 12
euros par touriste
en gagnant l'adhésion des communautés
locales les ong rewilding à s'est fixé
un nouvel objectif plus ambitieux la
réintroduction d'un félin emblématique
disparu d'argentine depuis plus de 60
ans à cause de la chasse et de la
déforestation
l'an dernier en 2021 on a libéré cette
jaguar un autre a été relâché le 1er
janvier 2022
ce sont des années de travail pour vivre
ce moment
dans cette zone inaccessible aux
touristes un seul enclos est occupée
actuellement par une femelle de 6 ans
baptisé mal où elle a été transférée
d'uruguay
loup est un animal qui vient d'un zoo
donc elle a beaucoup été en contact avec
l'homme donc elle ne pourra pas être
relâchés mais on peut la faire se
reproduire et ses petits eux pourront
être remis en liberté
dans quelques mois un jaguar mal
rejoindre amalou pour s'accoupler avec
elle
avec la réintroduction de ce
superprédateur c'est tout l'équilibré
d'un écosystème qui est assurée
il réguler les populations des grands
cervidés et aussi des plus petits
herbivore ce qui entraîne à son tour une
régulation des plus petits prédateurs
comme les renards par exemple tout ça va
aussi avoir un effet sur la diversité de
la végétation et la qualité du sol
quand elle aura ses petits mâles ou sera
déplacé avec eux dans un plus grand
enclos pour leur apprendre à chasser
sans aucun contact visuel avec l'homme
les jeunes jaguar pourront être libérés
dans un second temps grâce à tous ces
efforts le parc dit berra est
aujourd'hui le plus grand réservoir de
biodiversité d'argentine